I'm gonna deal with a few things that
I'm seeing around the room and then I
want to move you forward secondly here's
the first one have a look at my writing
here please do not write it down because
it's wrong that's why I've written it in
red I just want to understand why it's
wrong I have a look with me okay
first thing let me just walk you through
what I did I was like okay look this
thing here this is one of the chain rule
things that we've been seeing over and
over again so I know this is the inside
function x squared minus 1 is the
derivative of X square minus 1 to X as
I've written it looks like a there it is
right there I then looked at the rest of
it and I said oh the outside function is
this e to the power of a theme and I
know exactly what happens when you
differentiate something like that and so
nothing happens to it so I've written
down exactly as it was and then I just
kind of tied it up in a nice neat bow
can anyone tell me what went wrong set
it again a bit louder to her so so two
eyes pointed out when I first did
questions of this category in you know
write this a lesson I said this thing
here we should give it a name we should
do this substitution in the proper way
let u equal that then do my D yuan DX
and then chain my derivatives together
ok now my life it's files pointed that
out
however I will say for things like this
once you're starts to get familiar with
the chain rule you actually totally can
do this and you don't need to spend so
much time so while I think that would be
more what's the word I'm looking for
more comprehensive working out I don't
think it would be any more right or
wrong then what I've already written
here I've just kind of taken the
shortcut do you see something different
so view am I allowed to multiply the 2x
and the 3 times the other stuff what do
you think I've just got 2x times 3 and
I've written 6x what do you think no
people are not happy with that what
should I have done instead just just
leave it like that ok so I'm gonna I'm
gonna blow your little minds and I'm
gonna tell you at least last I checked
2x times 3 I'm down in my owner the ripa
tape 2x times 3 I'm pretty sure is 6x
and one of the things about
multiplication is that when you string
together a bunch of things that are
multiplied like say for example seven
times four times five right we can say
alright I can do twenty-eight times five
and I'll get the same answer yeah or I
could do seven times twenty and I'll get
the same answer whichever way you do it
which way you combine these things
you'll still get 140 right so I'm gonna
go out and say you know what that is
totally okay there's something else
missing something else little more
fundamental and it's something I've seen
written whoop flying pan
something else I've seen written on like
at least half a dozen pages around the
room this same era identical one sorry
Serrano is because I put it out to about
a minute ago right what's going wrong
answer see this thing here 3e to the but
Allah is that equal to this no it's not
it's not equal to that what am I done
what was I describing to you the process
that I was doing I was differentiating
thank you so I was changing this quite
substantially it would be this era this
era will be just like saying if I gave
you an exercise and it's all about
taking the square roots of a bunch of
numbers right back to you seven or so
like that and I said here's a number
right and I said take the square root
and you're like I know what the square
root of that is it's equal to five right
now this sentence is no more true than
this one is okay you did an operation to
this how would I fix this because I
can't fix it it's easy to fix to make
this I don't put a square root over it
and this is correct okay and the same
way up here how would I fix this the
thing I was doing was differentiating so
tell me that tell me right out the front
this is what I'm about to do the
derivative of that and then this is all
fine does that make sense
so I want you to look carefully at your
working and if you just instinctively
wrote down the question and then said oh
the thing I'm supposed to be doing at
the moment is in your case
differentiation and then write the
answer have a look please you're working
cuffs in a lot around the room that's
not true tell me what you're doing okay
now having looked down here there's a
very similar issue very similar closely
related issue have a look at it this is
also wrong
any power I've done ah there's my inside
function what's the derivative of the
inside function 3x squared take away 4
do you agree with that okay no yeah no
yeah again you make me doubt my
differentiation this is fine at least as
far as I'm concerned this is the
derivative of the inside function right
this is the other outside function e to
the power of a thing hasn't changed okay
where's the issue I've given you a big
clue by the way I talked about the first
one right yes yeah thank you see in here
right there's nothing there now this is
very important I did we had a
conversation about this just before D on
DX right which I'm you can see here and
here in all these kinds of these it's
what we call them operator it's called
the differential operator I showed you
another operator just on the board right
here the square root
it's an operator right it has to operate
on a number that's why it's called what
it is you've got to put something
underneath here like if I said the
square root of thin air right and then I
put an answer out here
that would not make sense do you agree
you've got to tell me what is the thing
you're taking the square root of in this
case it would be 16 right now over here
I have to write if you're
differentiating something tell me what
you're differentiating don't have D on
DX equals nothing it's the same with
square roots or logs or trig functions
like you wouldn't say sine and then
nothing
you'd say sine of an angle does that
make sense so we've been dealing with
operators for a long time you got to
handle them properly okay I didn't ask
you to write down any that because it
was wrong I would like you to write down
these though so I ask you to finish your
question underneath wherever you're
writing put this in place now what we're
gonna do here is combine our
understanding of calculus of exponential
functions where we did chain rule before
we're looking here at a this is a
reaction test anticipated this this is a
product and this guy here it's not a
product it's a it's division it's a
question right chill later a hearse has
been a little while how do use the
product rule and how use the quotient
rule in each case in each case we're
going to label each of the functions one
of them is U and one of them is V in
case of the protocol doesn't matter
which ones which it doesn't matter
because you can you know as we were just
pointing out you can rearrange a product
and it doesn't matter which way you
write it okay once you've labeled them
as such we can write the product rule in
this very compact and memorable form v u
- plus u v - which is very easy to
pronounce i pronounce it
Veuve okay there you go right can we do
this what's V what if i labeled v key ^
X okay the next part is you - I'm gonna
differentiate this first part here which
is 2x you know right that I'm done with
the first half now I move to the second
one the U in this case is right the
whole shebang
and then lastly V - when you
differentiate u to the X what do you get
just either parent it doesn't change so
at this point I've done all the
differentiation okay strictly speaking I
think that is fine but we could tie it
up just a teeny bit more so you know
notice something in common between those
two sets of terms yeah that e to the X
is in common right very good
so I could factorize that out and what
is that leave me with on there right
yeah or all of this stuff added together
I generally write them in the order of
their powers so this is probably the way
that I would write it that's it okay
you're you're waving hands at me and I
don't know what you mean okay so you're
fina factorizing further I'm actually
gonna suggest I don't think we can
factorize any further at least in this
case I'll leave that for you to have a
think about okay let's have a look at
this one now okay so we just rehearsing
the product rule okay here's the
question rule now just like before I'm
gonna label one of the parts of you and
one of parts of e doesn't matter which
one is which does it matter which one is
which we said for the Platt draw it in a
manual trans which you can call this one
Venus when you if you like does it
matter which one is which here it does
matter heck of a lot which one should we
call you and which one could we call V
we'll go from top to bottom that's you
and that's V why does it make a
difference
hmm I really want you to think about
that in strength sort of on the right
track but if he's got it why does it
matter here but it doesn't matter here
what do you think Sophie fantastic thank
you very much
let me just rehearse that right when
you're multiplying things if you should
know perfectly doesn't matter whether
you say 2 times 4 or 4 times 2 they're
the same thing yeah but when you're
dividing 2 over 4 is not the same as 4
over 2 so you can't just like call
whichever one you'd like right so once
you have appropriately labeled each one
the question rule if you write the
product rule like this the question will
rights very similar right you're going
to have the same V you - and the same
you V - what's different it's a - very
good not a plus and then there's another
difference it's the question rule so
this derivative is going to be itself a
question what's on the bottom V squared
fantastic so I set up the question role
and now I'm ready to use it okay move on
rewrite help me out ok now I've picked
these because they're the same ones you
knew before so we can just fit them in
two different spots is that ok so we
already know what V is it's e to the X
we already worked out what you - was
it's 2x and in fact I can rehearse my
whole front first line here right with a
minus sign instead of a plus so let's
put in that x squared minus 1 and that e
to the X like so then comes my
denominator what's my gentleman give me
yeah very good so this is V that's me
right there so I'm going to square the
whole thing either power of X as
somebody suggested in brackets then I
square it okay
now this point yes I can I can simplify
further
Conte let's do a bit of simplifying so
on the top just like earlier I'm gonna
factor I stuff out just be careful be
super super careful see that minus sign
this is like a silly mistake waiting to
happen
okay you got minus signs interacting
minus signs so I'm gonna do this real
carefully e to the X out the front okay
I've got the two X comes first minus the
x squared that - and that - that's a
plus very good so that's their
numerators done denominator what was
your suggestions frame for how to
simplify that fantastic those two powers
they're just gonna multiply together
power 2x but wait a second I can go
further can't I have a look you remember
how we factorized right so we saw all
that e to the X is in common on the
numerator but there's an EDX in common
with the denominator as well do you
agree like that is e to the x times e to
the X that's where we got it from right
so if I cancel e to the X on the top and
the bottom what will I get
okay I'm gonna get this stuff here 2x
surrounds and equals 9 minus x squared
plus 1 all divided by all divided by e
to the X because one of the EDX is
cancelled does that make sense okay I
cancel one off the top one of the bottom
I am done okay
I think so there's kind of like two
stages if you like to how we think about
this first you do the calculus bit and
then you have to think or your algebra
and you're simplifying index laws and so
on okay